Перехід через лінію зіткнення у Станиці Луганській.
Це "сіра зона", непідконтрольна українському уряду територія.
А за зруйнованим мостом - так звана "ЛНР",
не визнана навіть Росією, завдяки підтримці якої вона існує.
Приводом для створення сепаратистських республік і війни на Донбасі
став захист російськомовних громадян України.
Нині тисячі з них щодня перетинають лінію фронту.
На підконтрольну українському уряду територію йдуть,
щоб отримати пенсії, купити продукти або відвідати рідних.
Цікавимось, чи дійсно мовне питання є для них таким болючим, як стверджують у Кремлі.
Мені байдуже, якою мовою розмовляти
Я вважаю, що це не першочергове питання.
Це потрібно політикам, а не простим людям.
Я не підтримую, щоб російська стала офіційною регіональною мовою на Донбасі.
- Але ж ви розмовляєте російською?
Так. Ми завжди розмовляли російською,
тому що схід України був зрусифікований.
Нам, звісно, ближче російська, але думаємо ми все-таки як українці.
Тут козаки, розумієш? Мій батько, мати, всі мої предки - козаки.
Російською мовою розмовляли.
Навіщо забороняти мені розмовляти рідною мовою?
- Ніхто ж не забороняє.
- Ну, як це не забороняють? По телевізору показують,
що якщо російською розмовляєш - ти москаль,
тебе навіть заарештувати можуть.
Взагалі, в Україні головною повинна бути українська мова.
- Ви підтримуєте новий мовний закон?
- Я його не вивчала, не читала. Тож не можу нічого конкретного сказати.
Але я за те, щоб всі українці знали українську мову і українську культуру.
Всі роз’їхались, хто куди, і спілкуватися українською мовою нема з ким.
Але коли я іду сюди, мені приємно, я зі всіма розмовляю українською мовою.
Насамперед українська мова має бути національною.
Але російська також -адже навіть у Києві розмовляють російською.
Тому що так звикли. Проте це не означає, що я не люблю Україну.
Я теж патріот України.
Мовне питання для Донбасу абсолютно неважливе.
Це все піар-ходи. Тому що ми тут розмовляємо так само,
як у всій Україні. А по всій Україні
щонайменше половина людей розмовляє російською.
Необхідно надати статус регіональної російській мові
в Донецькій та Луганській областях тільки для того,
щоб розвіяти всі ці міфи про те, що це причина всіх наших бід.
Я народилась і живу на Донбасі. 59-го року народження
І завжди російська в школі була в пріоритеті.
Ніхто з першого класу не змушував навчатись українською.
Я українка, підтримую українську.
А говорити можу і російською, і українською - як завгодно.
І від цього, я так думаю, нічого не залежить.
Для мене головне - мир.
Якщо ти хороша людина - не важливо, якою мовою ти говориш.
Нещодавно голова партії "Слуга народу" Дмитро Разумков заявив,
що говоритиме російською під час телеефірів,
поки Донбас і Крим залишаються окупованими.
А президент Володимир Зеленський наголосив, що не бачить жодної проблеми
із використанням російської мови на Донбасі - зокрема, у документообігу.
Втім, цими сигналами нової влади або маніпулюють інші політики,
або ще не до кінця розуміють жителі окупованих територій.